hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our 1858
match between yohanyako blovental and
paul charles morphy
and uh of course elemental is still
hoping to uh win the match and to show
the world that he's better than
than paul morphy and uh some of you said
well not some of you i remember one
comment uh in the comment section
uh asked that how do we know that uh
loveentel actually challenged morphe
to clear his name or to show that he's
better
uh well here is a small part of
uh david lawson's book that talks about
this matter so i'm just going to read it
uh morphy had met lomental during his
first week in london
when the latter was still smarting from
staunton's publicity in may
about his defeat in 1850 by a boy not
yet 13. so we've covered this match at
their 1850 match
uh between uh morphine loventhal
lavental dust
lost no time in proposing a match to
clear the score
between them he doubtless thought the
chances of winning were in his favor
after having observed the morphe play
during during his first
week or so in england uh morphy had not
yet recovered completely from
the effects of the voyage of the voyage
in fact the match was delayed a few days
on account of it and then further and
and so on and so on
so here it clearly says that uh well
maybe not so clearly but it says that
uh to clear the score between them now
whether this is something that actually
happened or is this maybe
uh david lawson's observation of what
happened and then
he like decided that that's what took
place i have no idea
but i think it's safe to say that uh i
mean uh
of course uh lemental wanted to show
everyone that he's better than morphy in
those days i mean uh honor was
everything
and if you're wondering about the uh
title of the video
what kind of a mouse slip can occur in
1858
well uh you give me a better explanation
of the of a move that occurs in this
game
i i dare you so uh without further ado
let's check it out low intel with the
white pieces
opens with e4 uh sorry about that and
like i said this is game seven
out of the first six games morphe won
five and owenthal only one
so let's see if this could be another
turning point for
for guru yohanyako we have e5 by morphe
as he usually plays we knight f3 d6
going for philidor's defense and now d4
uh we have captures and queen captures
and now bishop to e6 knight to c6 would
be
pretty much an automatic nowadays but
morphy
preferred to delay moves like this maybe
to catch his opponent off guard maybe to
use it afterwards
maybe after more pieces were developed
or maybe to to provoke whites to maybe
go for some weaknesses that are not
actually weaknesses who knows why morphe
did stuff like this so okay
knight to c3 uh low until continues
development and
a6 now uh with bishop to e3 and now
knight to c6 now they're chasing away
the queen queen d2 and the knight to f6
and you're gonna see this game is played
really well by both sides like uh
especially by low intel and this is
something that happens
uh in a lot of game uh between uh morphe
and his uh contemporaries so let's see
what happens here
rook to d1 and it is as of move eight
that this position has never
uh occurred again uh with bishop to e7
morphe is ready to castle now
and bishop to e2 elemental does the same
we have castle's castles
uh and now b5 preparing b4 to
dislodge the knight maybe to to pick up
d for pawn so of course
elemental stops this he plays a3 we have
knight to e5
and now well you could trade this and
help morphy develop
instead just knight to e for declining
this trade
uh logan thought says i want to play f4
kick away or knight again
this c6 square for my knight which will
be awesome
so morphy says no you're not he pushes
the knight away we have c5
and forces this trade so captures
captures uh giving up the bishop pair
but
in return gaining a massive center here
so
f4 pushing the knight away knight to g6
and now just bishop to f3 improving the
position of your
well we could say of your least active
piece so this is uh
this is an excellent move f5 might be uh
preferable to
the sun but uh bishop to f3 a very nice
move uh the
the rook is now being x-rayed e5 is the
threat so of course amorphy moves the
rook rook b8 prepares b4 at some point
and queen to e2 now getting the queen
out of the d
file preparing e5 yet again and here
queen to c7 morphe uh moves the queen
away from the c
f from the d file and this is the
position
uh from the thumbnail well almost we're
almost there one more move
uh where white has an excellent position
he's doing incredibly well
uh it's an it's a really open position
white still has the bishop pair
uh he he controls more space and uh well
all in all he should just uh slowplay it
and slowly but surely improve his
position with moves like g3
uh and so on uh maybe shifting his queen
away grabbing the
the hold of this diagonal even more and
well
basically you need to play anything here
uh
other than what was played in the game
so you need to prepare for b4
uh stuff like that and you do have
excellent control of the d5 square so
black will always have troubles
executing d5 and these two points might
become weaknesses in the future
so here elemental plays h4 and there is
no good explanation for
why someone would play this move so you
play h4 okay obviously you're
preparing to push this pawn to h5 uh but
what happens
after the pawn is captured so murphy
asks the same question
he plays knight captures on h4 and now
says
and and then uh and okay we have bishop
to g4
going after the pawn here probably
hoping morphy will mess up
with moves like uh hard to say uh
putting his queen maybe on a weird
square but morphy just captures it and
after captures again this is attacked so
you need to be careful not to mess it up
with something
like this and allow this let's say
bishop captures uh but morphy says okay
just
queen to c8 and still wha what is your
plan here
so uh my knight is defended uh the pawn
is defended
what did you gain with this uh well with
this sacrifice
and here we have g3 and this is really
weird so
the h pawn sacrifice might even be
uh justified if you played something
like f5 here to take away the g6 square
from the black's knight
it still doesn't work but we might say
that okay maybe
maybe the pawn sacrifice is okay uh but
just to show you why it doesn't work
black continues with his play on the
queen side b4
captures captures he pushes away the
knight so first a nice
mate threat and now that's a weird arrow
so after the
mate threat has been made bishop f6 uh
defending mate and now
knight to e2 and here we can just play e
captures an f5 he captures on f5
and well it seems like white has
definitely made progress
and that the pawn sacrifice is justified
black can just go knight g6
and the knight is back in the game you
cannot capture because the
uh the pawn is pinned so black gets the
knight into the game and all is well but
uh it would be it would be a reasonable
move to play here
uh so here uh g3 was played allowing
morphy's knight to come back into the
game right away we have
knight to g6 and now rook to f2 now
preparing to double up rooks and the f
file and also b4 is coming so you do
want to have a radio defender of the c2
pawn
morphy says okay rook f6 i'm going to
add another defender here move my queen
probably double up rooks on the f file
and uh well everything depends on what
you do next we have rook d to
f1 and now just b4 we have captures
captures and
knights to a for now so the c2 pawn is
defended nicely that's fine
but now queen to c6 by morphe with a
double attack here on the pawn and
under knight b3 you cannot defend
against both
and morphy just captures it so grabbing
yet another pawn we
and also attacking the bishop we have
bishop to a7 attacking the rook and now
just
rook b to f8 now doubling up on the f
file we have rook to e2 pushing morphy's
queen away
and the queen to b7 now uh
getting the queen out of harm's way also
the bishop is under attack we have
bishop back to f2 uh and here uh
well uh black's position is just
terrible but
uh you know feel free to pause the video
and win this game for morphe it's an
instant win
uh well i'll give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting
the the the immediate resign
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show any move wins here e5 wins h5 wins
so you can pretty much play any move
because the position is winning but the
move morphe played knight captures on f4
uh it's an instant resign and it is in
fact in this position that yohanyako
blumenthal resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here
uh the point is uh let's see what
happens if you capture the knight if you
capture then i just rook to g6 and
the queen is lost there's nothing you
can do about that
if you don't capture the knight well
then your rook is hanging but
also there's the threat of checkmate
just queen to g2 so you cannot defend
against both threats
uh you can't even stop checkmate you
cannot play queen f3 you cannot play
queen to h3
you could play queen captures on f4 uh
but that's
also just uh that's also just uh giving
up the queen and you don't really
gain much by doing this so after knight
f4 white is uh really really without a
move
and of course it was uh in this position
on move 28 that yohanyako blumenthal
resigned the game
so uh very very nice victory uh game
seven also goes to paul morphy so it's
six to one in morphy's favor and
luintel not not very close the uh well
uh getting his revenge for losing that
match to morphy in 1850
uh but yeah that's uh that's the game i
do hope you enjoyed it uh really weird
stuff that happens to morphe's opponents
i mean it all started
with barnes but you can see that yeah
it's a reoccurring theme with all of
morphe's opponents they understand the
basic principles they know that they
need rapid development they need to
place
uh you know rooks on open lines they
know they have to place their pieces
well on the board but then when they uh
have to find a reasonable plan on how to
continue playing this game
like here like like a move like g3 or
just you know
uh keep everything solid this is where
they fall apart and this is where
morphe got most of his easy wins
but it's not morphy's fault that his
opponents play moves like this i mean
if your opponent plays a bad move of
course you're gonna take advantage of
that
uh but uh you know later on morphy will
face
some very much stronger opponents who
will not make mistakes like this and
then it's going to be very enjoyable to
see how morphe deals with them
uh but yeah all in all that's the game i
do hope you enjoyed it
uh a mouse slip in 1858 as as you can
see i mean uh
if you have a better explanation i'm all
ears uh i would like to thank
matt reichenbach uh peter waddek uh
marco lepozich uh kevin walker and
alexandre lenore for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the good stuff checking up
on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens uh in the
chess world uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day